Philip what is this huh Scott the new
flu or a new at other people you thought
I had run out of all the ideas that I
had didn't you oh no no still got
creative original ideas you laugh you
lose and other people's your life you
lose that's right we're gonna react to
people reacting to things and see who
laughs first and you're gonna watch me
reacting to other people reacting to
original clips how did we end up here
20:18 okay let's begin with my man
markiplier now he's been stealing my
thumbnails for quite a while it's kind
of been bugging me a little bit I didn't
want to start any drama or anything like
that but you can clearly tell I don't
know what quality camera more cast but
it looks amazing
cigarette yeah
sometimes I like to smoke down this is
exciting because now it's like a
challenge you know I'm not psychopathic
person that needs a challenge to
everything against another person of
course maybe there's a challenge to
myself then I always win I guess this
means I'm winning I didn't even what
happened
cigarette yeah sometimes I'd like to
smoke down here dad was pretty funny oh
okay I get replay on that one alright a
little pro tip for mark here this clip I
know another company owns so mark shows
this clip that company's gonna claim the
revenue out of this entire video which
means mark you're potentially losing
$50,000 on this video so already I know
mark it doesn't care about money which
means I'm not gonna watch his clips
right I'm done again okay so I mind but
on the inside
okay so you might read a blog feed the
quarter-final serve your sentence the
stolen goods are now for fees and
payment they look strangely symbol there
don't they damn what the hell
it's like Asian and gender mark at the
same shot I've seen these type Rio it's
one funny I guess I lost
[Music]
if
yes we have different I I guess we have
differences about looks like Marcus
Christ this guy makes legendary scaring
parodies they're so funny I've seen it
and it's hilarious mark
there you go all right one one me vs.
mark
I can't let mark win fine just think of
how delicious yummy you're gonna make a
great sandwich
in fact I named you after your eventual
fate well we can't have the girl die so
how about the pig guys why is that guy
still wearing a plastic bag on his head
mark what's wrong with you how can you
laugh at this this is so sad no no one's
talking to you - fine okay
- one mark blood it's great this is
souls owned by another company mark do
you hate money you know what just ask me
okay just ask me before the video and
I'll make sure you cut anything that you
don't need you clearly have room to cut
it and then just give the money to me
silly market cares more about good
content and making revenue what is this
Star Wars dubbed by Japanese
it's gonna be horrific ly racist over
Anakin I have a tiger and Oh
you under a Phoenix or my color all
right fine
all right fine I'm still in the lead we
both black all right I gotta take a
picture of marks face here it's so cute
that's my new background this is so cute
[Music]
like it stopped being funny after a
while Oh
you may add that you're saying mom I
know that so you wanna go this so no
it's not going down
clearly it's not being funny it's a pile
of bulls okay yeah don't look at me like
is yeah that was a Oh cringe man
I've seen this as well owned by now the
company don't even like even if I show
the still frame that would claim the
video that's how in same YouTube system
in right now I'm gonna take those guys I
won against you mark mark if you want to
do what you laugh you lose it's probably
not enough content actually but see if
you can beat me on another one feel free
to feel free to do that and check out
mark or more you laughs you lose videos
people just can't have enough of them
now moving on to Jack septic I to
welcome back to jacksepticeye's Funniest
Home Videos it's me your dad all right
here we go
me versus Jack Oh
[Applause]
Oh No
Oh
jack has the same issue with that
[ __ ] dammit laughs yeah man I love it
Dermott Jack damn it alright fine
1.2 jack see if I care this it's
supposed to be Funniest Home Videos why
are you guys sending me this creepy also
please edit out Jack's where there I
don't know why you could sing solo to
swear on your videos Jack you have kids
watching jacksepticeye ignores crying
fan are you kidding me are you kidding
me hey just read the title my really
pretty isn't oh god dog beeps what did
you do Adele the singer has over 16
million subs on the late show earlier
and they that does not count by the way
cuz the video hasn't started I you're
about to meet an Irish fellow has over
18 subscribers that's good he is over 18
subscribers has over 18 subscribe revoke
that is kudos
it's not what I do oh you might not have
heard of them but to millions it's kind
of a big deal would you give a welcome
please to Shaun McLaughlin also known as
to Kyle it looks like madam Muniz is
here hi Adam a fourteen-year from
Wicklow and you have a question yeah and
do you have any advice I'm like people
starting each other like head get more
subscriber subscribe to our Channel
I don't know if I should say or not you
can try no I keep that under wraps
ok is too painful I can't can't believe
you did that jack that's funny
it's fun laugh with other people
actually like this I think you
understand might be you guys click on
these videos now see if we laugh at this
I don't even know how you make these
these are always super impressive are
you kidding me Jack granny I love you
but these are not hard day
salsa with out oh my god Jack goddamnit
think that this for so long just keeps
going and going and then where's the
punchline
it's never funny Africa then okay great
all the scientists that it's four
quarters for an hour but a quarter only
gets you fifteen minutes so if my math
is correct that's not an hour rewind
take that off take that off you're right
fifteen minutes is it cool god I do not
do drugs I have not had liquor jack damn
it just a beer in your empathy jack fine
you win this round but next time I'll
get you jack smash like once if you beat
mark smash like two wives if you beat me
it's much like three times and subscribe
if you beat all of yours scattered it
further adue youtubes show everybody and
I'll see you guys next time bye
I needed to get ahead a videos that's
why I shot this video and sorry it's not
very good
[Music]